as it relates to the richard sherman
situation
that broke last week when i was at the
beach and we had plenty of stories about
it at pft
and uh it
it sounds like things are under control
for now and that's good for him and his
family we wish them the best and we hope
this situation can be managed in a
successful way
and whatever occurred last week won't
happen again
from a football standpoint i don't know
enough about what's going on with
richard sherman to know whether it's
good for him or not good for him to be
on a team
it could be that it's in his best
interest to sign with someone
to get to a training camp and to benefit
from the structure
of being in a locker room with his
teammates back in an environment where
he's comfortable where he's familiar
whether it's back with the 49ers back
with the seahawks or with a new team
that could help him immensely at this
point and and my broader point is
given the fact that he's facing five
misdemeanors
the nature of the accusations the facts
that resulted in these five charges
the league could decide to put him on
paid leave and
my point is as it relates to sherman as
it relates to sean watson
as it related two years ago to antonio
brown the league
should not use the potential of paid
leave
as some sort of a guessing game and oh
hey you know
hey if if the saints are interested in
signing richard sherman and they contact
the league office will you tell us
whether or not he's going to be put on
paid leave no we're not going to tell
you well why wouldn't
you tell the saints or anyone else
whether or not that's going to happen
because
in a situation like that it operates as
a deterrence
just like you did with antonio brown he
served a 14-game
unpaid suspension as a practical matter
because the league wouldn't tell
any of the teams that were interested in
antonio brown whether or not he was
going to be put on paid leave
for the accusations he was facing at the
time and that's just wrong just let
everyone know where the guy stands
he'll be put on paid leave or he won't
be put on paid leave and
for richard sherman if the league
refuses to say so that becomes a
potential impediment to him joining a
team
so that's why i believe as to sherman as
to watson
as to brown as to any other player who
possibly could end up on paid leave
the league needs to conduct the
preliminary investigation
under the personal conduct policy come
to a decision
and even if a guy currently isn't signed
by any team
let everyone know what his status is
going to be
so everyone can make the right decision
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports